Professor Robert Shiller:
I want to talk today about
the efficient markets
hypothesis.
Let me just first say,
last lecture was about
insurance and I was telling you
about the theory of insurance
and how it has evolved over the
years and how it has produced
some real benefits.
Is that better?
It says, "Mike volume."
I wanted to just tie this
in--the advantages of insurance
that we have to some big events
that occurred and that will,
I think, point out the
strengths and weaknesses of our
institutions.
We had a terrible hurricane a
couple of years ago in Los
Angeles;
Hurricane Katrina damaged the
city of--I'm sorry did I say Los
Angeles?
You have to stop me when I say
things that are obviously wrong.
My mind lapses sometimes--New
Orleans--and Los Angeles doesn't
have to worry about hurricanes
as far as I know,
unless there's some major
change.
In New Orleans there was a
Hurricane Katrina;
it broke the levies that were
surrounding the city and caused
the flooding of the city.
What saved the people of the
city, mostly?
I would say it was actually the
insurance institutions because
the city was heavily damaged but
homes were generally insured.
There were some conflicts when
this huge disaster came.
Some people had wind insurance
and some people had flood
insurance and it became
difficult whether this was a
wind or a flood problem,
because the wind caused the
flood.
So, if you had only wind
insurance are you covered?
There was a lot bickering and
arguments afterwards but I think
it worked out well.
There were surveys of customer
satisfaction after the event and
I think, generally,
people were happy with their
insurance companies.
Of course, there were some that
were not, who may have found out
that they weren't covered;
but on the whole,
the experience worked well.
The other thing I want to say
about the last lecture is that
as financial progress moves on,
the distinction between
insurance and other forms of
risk management may get blurred.
One very interesting thing
that's been happening is that we
are starting to see development
of another institution called
the catastrophe bond,
which is another way that
people have for protecting
themselves against catastrophes
and it's not insurance.
A catastrophe bond is a bond
that the issuer doesn't have to
pay off if there's a
catastrophe.
You could have hurricanes--the
City of New Orleans could raise
money with catastrophe bonds
that they have to pay back if
there's no hurricane but they
don't have to pay back if there
is a hurricane.
Or it could be some mixture:
they'd pay back part of it if
there is a hurricane.
That's like insurance, isn't it?
But it doesn't operate through
an insurance company,
it operates through a
securities market.
A good example of that is a
couple of years ago the
Government of Mexico issued
catastrophe bonds against
earthquakes.
Mexico City was hit by a
terrible earthquake about twenty
years ago and it's vulnerable to
being hit again.
So, what does Mexico do about
this?
Mexico could wait until there
is a hurricane (sic) and hope
that there's some international
relief effort,
but that's not a very good way
to proceed.
We want to arrange it in
advance.
What Mexico did was issue cat
bonds that have to be repaid in
the absence of a hurricane and
have a lower repayment if there
is--I'm sorry,
I'm not on my best form
today--earthquake.
Mexico City does not have to
worry about hurricanes either.
Every area is different and
they have their own individual
characteristics.
Right now, the insurance
industry is a bit challenged
because--in terms of some
risks--because the risks seem to
be changing through time and,
notably, it looks like
hurricane risk is increasing.
So people who are insured
in--it seems to be increasing
because of global warming,
although I don't know if all
scientists are agreed on that.
If you live in a coastal area
of Florida it does appear that
your risk is increasing through
time.
So insurance companies want to
raise your rates and this is a
huge issue down in Florida.
Well, the government has kind
of taken over for the time
being--insurance in
Florida--because we have
problems.
People are having problems
paying the increased insurance
premium.
I don't think we've figured out
finally how insurance will
ultimately look in a matter of
years.
But, I think that the important
thing is that it's protecting
against us already,
maybe imperfectly,
but it's already protecting us
against some of our worst fears,
like hurricanes and earthquakes.
I think the system is evolving
and we're getting new
developments like cat bonds that
are changing the way we're doing
things.
In the future,
I think these will develop more
and make us even better able to
handle catastrophe risks.
Anyway, that's the last lecture.
Today I wanted to talk
about--back to securities
markets or actually,
more general,
asset markets.
I want to talk today about the
efficient markets hypothesis,
which is a very important
intellectual construct that has
guided a lot of theory in
finance.
I want to talk first about the
history of the hypothesis--I
haven't defined it yet for you
but maybe you already have heard
of this--but history of the
hypothesis,
the arguments for it,
and then the arguments against
it.
I want to talk about technical
analysis and empirical evidence
in the literature--about
technical analysis--and other
schools of thought that doubt
the market efficiency,
talk somewhat about behavioral
economics.
Then, finally,
we have a homework assignment;
actually, it's coming up.
I'll start talking about it now
so you--it will be an assignment
for you to try to forecast the
stock market using statistical
methods.
You don't have to look at the
screen yet;
I'll come back to that.
What is the efficient markets
hypothesis?
The term actually is a fairly
recent origin--that is,
a few decades ago--but the idea
goes back much further.
The idea is that in asset
markets that have good
regulations and market makers
and developed markets that have
a lot of depth and liquidity--in
these markets,
the prices that you see are
perfect indicators of true
value.
In other words,
efficient market says that the
market efficiently incorporates
all information and the prices
are like the best information
about the value of something.
In other words,
efficient markets hypothesis
tells you: trust markets,
don't trust people,
trust markets.
I've been trying to find out
who said that first.
The earliest statement of the
efficient markets hypothesis,
although it doesn't call it the
efficient markets
hypothesis--the earliest
statement that I could find
comes from a book written in
1889 by George Gibson and it's
called The Stock Exchanges of
London,
Paris, and New York.
I'll quote him,
he said, "When shares become
publicly-known in an open
market,
the value, which they acquire
there, may be regarded as the
judgment of the best
intelligence concerning them."
I was kind of interested to see
this book.
I found it in the Mudd Library,
actually by accident,
looking through old stock
market books.
The book had some interesting
observations.
One observation,
which took my interest,
was that he points out that in
this modern electronic age
information speeds around the
globe at the speed of
electricity--or the speed of
light.
When I first read that I
thought for a minute,
wait a minute,
1889?
That sounds like 1989 or
something.
Just a moment.
We found the microphone.
Oh, it was right there?
Now I am free from my tether.
In 1889, they had already
invented the telegraph.
In fact, that goes back decades
earlier.
The telephone was starting to
appear, so it really was true
that information would speed
around the globe.
Information that became
publicly-known would be entered
into market price almost
immediately.
The conclusion that Gibson had
was that there's no hope in
trying to beat the price or beat
the market because the price
already has all of the
information in it.
Let me elaborate on that theme
a little bit.
Actually, it goes back before
telegraph, there was a famous
story of Mr.
Reuters, who had an information
service before the telegraph was
invented.
He wanted to help his clients
get the information first so
that they could trade on it and
he had the idea of using what
you call carrier pigeons.
What you do is you get these
birds and you raise them--you
know what I'm talking about,
right?
You raise them in one place and
then they're going to want to go
back there.
Then you take them away in a
cage to another city and when
you need to get a message
across, you tie the message to
the pigeon's foot and release
it.
Then it will fly back and it
will beat any other method of
message transmission.
Incidentally,
Reuter's information service is
still in business today and now
they use computers the way
everyone else does,
but the whole principle
precedes the invention of
computers.
The idea is that the only way
you can beat the market is to
get information that nobody else
has.
The way it works today is that
the--we can't actually improve
on the speed from 1889 because
they were already going at
virtually the speed of light
with their information;
but, we can improve on our
access to it.
Now, many people have beepers
or something like this in their
pocket that wakes up and tells
them when news is announced.
What happens where there's news
about a stock?
Let's say it's a drug company
that just makes an announcement
that it has a new drug--let's
say good news--or it has gotten
FDA approval to market some new
drug.
Well, it would put that out
over the network of information
and some people would have their
things beep on them and alert
them immediately.
There are analysts who try to
keep up with news about stocks.
So, these analysts then would
jump to action when they hear
news like that.
That's because they know that
markets move really fast to
important new information and
they've got to be there first.
What happens when the drug
company announces that they have
some news--important news?
Well, the guys who are with
their beepers immediately spring
to action and try to figure out
what the news is.
Within seconds they're trading
because you know you've got to
be there first;
otherwise, you can't benefit
from the news.
What happens?
They say they've
announced--they've got approval
for this new drug.
Then maybe do a quick call to
their drug company expert and
say, quick how much should I
change the valuation of this
stock?
The guy will give a quick
guess--this is now twenty
seconds after the
announcement--and then
immediately you place a big
trade for a million shares or
plus or minus.
Then the guy calls back thirty
seconds later and says,
"Oh no, I wasn't exactly right
on that.
I've had thirty more seconds to
think about this,
so let me change it again."
Over the next few minutes,
the price--a lot of people are
trading like that so the price
is jumping around rapidly.
Then, after maybe five minutes,
these people have had time to
assimilate it and think about it
and check their thinking and the
price starts to settle down.
Maybe I'm exaggerating how fast
it settles down.
Maybe an hour later you have a
committee meeting and the
experts are arguing about what
this really means and trying to
assimilate other information and
coordinate with it;
but, after two hours it started
to really settle down.
Suppose you then,
the next day,
read in The Wall Street
Journal about this new
announcement.
Do you think you have any
chance of beating the market by
trading on it?
I mean, you're like twenty-four
hours late, but I hear people
tell me--I hear,
"I read in Business Week
that there was a new
announcement,
so I'm thinking of buying."
I say, "Well,
Business Week--that
information is probably a week
old."
Even other people will talk
about trading on information
that's years old,
so you kind of think that maybe
these people are naïve.
First of all,
you're not a drug company
expert or whatever it is that's
needed.
Secondly, you don't know the
math--you don't know how to
calculate present values,
probably.
Thirdly, you're a month late.
You get the impression that a
lot of people shouldn't be
trying to beat the market.
You might say,
to a first approximation,
the market has it all right so
don't even try.
The efficient markets
hypothesis is a hypothesis that
one should respect financial
markets very much.
Your textbook by Fabozzi, et al.
mentions--I looked it up in the
index to see what they say about
efficient markets hypothesis.
They define it.
I'm quoting the textbook
Fabozzi, "Publicly-available,
relevant information about the
issuers will lead to correct
pricing of freely-traded
securities in
properly-functioning markets."
That's their definition of the
efficient markets hypothesis.
They didn't say it was right;
they just said that's the
hypothesis.
What Fabozzi, et al.
said is that the hypothesis has
informed a lot of regulation.
The Securities and Exchange
Commission and other agencies
that regulate financial markets
have shown some faith in the
efficient markets hypothesis.
Therefore, they feel that
their--maybe their primary
mission is to regulate the flow
of information to make sure that
it's an even playing field so
that everyone has access to
information at the same time.
For example,
the Securities and Exchange
Commission requires that when a
corporation publishes
information that's relevant to
the value of their stock,
they have to put it out to
everyone at once or there's
rules about what that means.
Typically, they'll have a
webcast or something like that
and it's announced in advance,
so everyone who is really
interested can listen in.
I don't find a whole lot of
enthusiasm in the Fabozzi book
for the efficient markets
hypothesis and maybe that's
because it's not exactly right,
which is my view.
It's a half truth;
I'll come back to that.
I want to quote another
best-selling textbook,
not your own,
but there's another textbook,
Brealey and Myers,
which is a textbook of
corporate finance.
They are much more enthusiastic
about efficient markets
hypothesis.
At the end of their textbook,
they have a concluding chapter
and the concluding chapter is
built around what they call the
"seven most important ideas in
finance."
One of those seven ideas to
them is efficient markets.
They don't call it a
hypothesis, they just say
"efficient markets," which they
define as the theory that--I'm
quoting them,
"Security prices accurately
reflect available information
and respond rapidly to new
information as soon as it
becomes available."
Then they have a little
qualifier--I think this is
interesting--they say,
"Don't misunderstand the
efficient market idea,
it doesn't say that there are
no taxes or costs.
It doesn't say that there
aren't some clever people and
some stupid ones.
It merely implies that
competition in capital markets
is very tough.
There are no money machines and
security prices reflect the true
underlying value of assets."
That's a pretty enthusiastic
endorsement of efficient
markets.
I said I have some doubts about
it.
I guess I don't--I guess what I
don't like is their concluding
statement, "Security prices
reflect the true underlying
value of assets."
I don't think that's really
true but I guess I agree,
it's tough to make money
reliably and quickly in
financial markets.
So, if that's what efficient
markets means,
they're right.
"Efficient markets" is not so
easy to define.
We can go back to--the term
really goes back to 1967 and it
was Professor Harry Roberts at
University of Chicago who
defined three different
efficient markets hypotheses.
There's the weak form,
the semi-strong form,
and then the strong form.
The weak form--these differ
only in terms of the amount of
information that is assumed to
be efficiently incorporated into
prices.
The weak form says that
information of past prices is
already in the--incorporated
into price, but only past
prices.
What it means "only" is that
you can't predict stock prices
by noting that,
say,
if it goes up today,
it'll probably go up tomorrow
or it goes up today,
it'll probably go down
tomorrow.
That would be relying only on
past prices.
Harry Roberts felt most
confident that this form of the
hypothesis was good,
so he called it the weak form;
it's the least criticizable
form of efficient markets.
Semi-strong form says that
market prices incorporate all
public information.
Anything that's known to the
public is already incorporated
into price, so don't bother to
trade on it.
The strong form says all
information, whether public or
not, is incorporated into price.
This is a really strong--it's
the least likely to be true
because every time you increase
the information set--what strong
form says is that no information
is private,
really, it all gets out into
price.
Companies keep secrets,
so that's not public
information.
The Securities and Exchange
Commission insists that
companies keep secrets because
they have to disseminate
information in an orderly way.
So, there has to be a secret
until a certain hour in which
it's announced to everybody.
But the strong form efficient
markets hypothesis is cynical
about that and says,
you know, nobody keeps secrets,
it all leaks out.
I think that when we refer to
the efficient markets
hypothesis, it's the semi-strong
form that we're usually
referring to because the strong
form is a bit strong.
The definitions of efficient
markets that I gave you are
intuitive but not very precise.
Then you have to ask,
well what does it mean to say
that price incorporates all
information?
What does it mean to
incorporate information?
Unfortunately,
there's not one answer to that
question, so I'm going to give
the simplest answer.
What does efficient markets
mean?
I might--I'll have to--this is
the simplest version but it's
often the one that is referred
to most.
That is that price is the
expected value--the expected
present value--of future
dividends paid on a stock.
The efficient markets
hypothesis says,
the true value of a stock comes
from the dividends that it
pays--that's a cash flow that is
valued by the market and the
market values it as the present
value of the
optimally-forecasted future
dividends.
The theory that's most often
referred to is the simple--I've
already talked in the second
lecture about present value
formulas;
we had a growing-perpetuity
model.
Remember that I said that the
present value--the present
discounted value of a growing
perpetuity that pays an amount
D--well,
if it pays De^(gt) or
D_0e^(gt) is
the dividend,
so it's growing at rate,
g.
Then, the formula we had for
the present value was
D/(r-g).
Remember that?
This assumes,
of course, that the growth of
dividends has to be less than
the discount rate,
r.
The simplest version of the
efficient markets hypothesis
says, price is equal to the
dividend all over the discount
rate minus the growth rate of
dividends,
where g,
the growth rate of dividends,
is an optimally-forecasted
growth rate of dividend.
That gives us a value--a model
for the price.
Another way of writing,
more generally--if I don't
assume the constant growth rate
of dividends--is to write just a
present value formula.
It's another less strong form
of writing down the efficient
markets hypothesis because it
doesn't say how dividends are
thought to grow.
But you can write:
price is equal to the summation
of E(D_t+k)]/(1 +
r)^(k);
k = 1 to infinity.
This is another--that's just
the present value formula.
I have the price--I'm sorry,
this should be expectation at
time, t--the price at
t is the expectation of
the dividend,
at time t plus k,
discounted by a discount factor
r. That's just the
present value formula where I've
substituted an expectation for
the future dividend.
That's the efficient markets
theory in this incarnation.
There are other ways to
envision the efficient
markets--what it means--but
let's consider this simple
story.
What this means then is that
the price is a forecast of
future dividends to be paid on
the stock.
This would be--of the present
value of future dividends to be
paid on the stock--and this
means then that price,
relative to dividend,
is related to expected future
growth rates of dividends.
If you expect dividends to grow
a lot, if g is high,
then price will be high,
relative to dividends,
because this is subtracted off
the denominator.
It makes the denominator
smaller and it makes the price
higher.
On the other hand,
if you expect dividends to do
poorly in the future,
then price will be low relative
to dividends;
that's what the efficient
markets hypothesis would say.
I would give you an example of
that.
I talked last year about a
company that I read in
Business Week--that I
read about in Business
Week,
so this is a year old story in
Business Week.
There was a company called
First Federal Financial,
which was a company that issues
mortgages.
This was in January of 2007,
actually the Business
Week story was in December
of 2006,
but I was still reacting to it
a year ago, in January of 2007.
The Business Week
story--this is First Federal
Financial--was referring to the
fact that the price-dividend
ratio--actually they talked
about price-earnings ratio,
but the price-earnings ratio
for this company was very low.
It was only 8.5 in December
2006.
Typically, price-earnings
ratios of the companies are very
high, much higher than
that--typically like fifteen.
The price of First Federal
Financial, relative to its
earnings, was very low,
so some people might be
inclined to think well that
looks cheap.
I can buy--by buying First
Federal Financial,
I can buy the stock at a low
price relative to its earnings.
But, if you believe in
efficient markets you wouldn't
think that this is any reason to
buy the company because
efficient markets would say that
if the price is low relative to
either dividends or earnings,
it must mean that people think
that bad things are going to
come to the dividends or
earnings.
In other words,
the First Federal Financial has
a low expected growth rate of
dividends in the future.
So, I was interested in this
particular story because
Business Week wrote an
article about them and noted the
low price-earnings ratio and
said,
what does this mean?
What Business Week
presented a year ago was an
argument why g was likely
to be low.
Yes?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Robert
Shiller: If they don't pay
dividends you can't use this
formula.
I'm not sure what the dividends
were at First Federal Financial.
I only know the price-earnings
ratio at that time.
You're right,
you cannot use this formula if
they're not paying a dividend
today because this formula--I
erased it,
but it was up here--assumes
that dividends are following a
growth path.
If they're not paying a
dividend, then we're very
clearly--that's not an
appropriate assumption.
Student: So how would
the efficient market theory
explain prices of companies that
do not pay dividends?
Professor Robert
Shiller: Right.
So for–incidentally,
if you know,
Berkshire Hathaway is the
company Warren Buffett owns and
it's a very famous company
because it's done extremely
well.
Warren Buffett is regarded as,
by many people,
as the financial genius.
If Berkshire Hathaway is not
paying a dividend,
we have to revert to this
formula.
The efficient market theory
would say, well they're going to
pay a dividend eventually,
so the price reflects these
future terms.
If you spell this out,
this is the expected dividend
next year plus the dividend in
two years--this is divided by (1
+ r)^(2)--the expected
dividend in three years divided
by (1 + r)^(3),
etc.
This theory would say that the
dividend--that Berkshire
Hathaway has value only because
they--investors expect them to
pay dividends in the future.
That sounds right because if
Berkshire Hathaway is never
going to pay dividends,
why would you hold it?
You might say,
I'll hold it because I could
sell to someone else at a higher
price.
But then you say,
well why would anyone else buy
it?
Look, if they're never going to
pay a dividend,
what good is it?
It's just a piece of paper,
unless I can sell to a greater
fool.
But anyone who buys it is
either--would be buying it
either on the assumption that
there's some greater fool coming
or they would be a fool
themselves.
This theory says that the
value--if Warren Buffett--of
course, he can't even say this,
but let's somehow say the
company could say,
we will never pay a dividend.
This company is going to give
itself away to charity someday
and you won't get a penny as a
stockholder.
Well, if that happened the
price should be zero.
It would convert into a
non-profit, like Yale
University.
So what's the price of a share
in Yale University?
I mean, it's undefined--I its
guess zero, right?
Because Yale is not
paying--I'll write a piece of
paper for you and say this is a
share.
On my authority,
this is a share in Yale
University.
It might just as well be that
because it also says in my fine
print, you will never get a
dividend on this.
So what's the point, right?
Incidentally,
Microsoft for many years never
paid a dividend.
It's often common for young
companies not to pay dividends;
but they did start paying a
dividend.
The whole theory--efficient
markets theory--says that that's
what people are looking for.
That's why the value of a
company is related to its
activities;
otherwise, if the company never
paid a dividend,
then what would you care what
the company is doing?
You only care about it because
someday they're going to give
you money.
A lot of investors forget that;
that's a very naïve
attitude.
They think that somehow stocks
generate capital gains--prices
go up--but you have to realize
and efficient markets theory is
saying this: prices only go up
because there's new information
about future dividends.
First Financial anyway--this is
an efficient markets
story--First Financial had a low
P/E, so people were wondering,
is this a bargain?
This is a cheap stock--P/E
means price-earnings ratio.
The Business Week
article pointed out that 40% of
First Federal had been sold
short--40% of their stock had
been sold short;
this is a very high level of
shortage.
You know what means?
That means a lot of investors
said, "I don't like First
Federal Financial,
I don't want to invest in it.
Worse than that,
I want to go and short them."
That means you borrow shares
and sell them and hope that the
price goes down.
When you have 40% of the shares
sold short that means that there
were a lot of people who didn't
believe in First Federal
Financial.
Business Week,
in its article,
pointed out that this--First
Federal Financial was a small
mortgage lender--this is before
the mortgage crisis that we have
started--in Santa Monica,
California.
And it was particularly
innovative, in a sense,
in its lending.
Notably, 80%,
according to the Business
Week article,
80% of the mortgages it's
issued were no-doc mortgages.
Do you know what a no-doc
mortgage is?
It's something that appeared
recently in the housing frenzy.
A no-doc mortgage is a mortgage
where you walk in and say,
"I want to borrow money to buy
this house."
The company says,
"Fine we'll give you a
mortgage.
We won't even ask you to have
your employer send a letter
saying that you have a job.
We won't even ask you to prove
that you own anything or
have--we'll just give you the
mortgage."
That's considered by many
people risky behavior but it was
done during the housing boom.
Also, they issued an unusually
high proportion of what are
called "option ARMs." These are
mortgages that are
adjustable-rate,
but the person doesn't have to
pay the full payment every time.
You have the option of paying
and if you don't want to pay,
you can delay it for a while.
These are also controversial
because it thought they would
attract borrowers who were
unreliable.
Borrowers who thought that they
could afford the house because
they didn't have to pay now;
but of course,
it's all going to come later
and then they might default.
Business Week thought
that the low price-earnings
ratio was because the market
expected earnings to go down and
dividends to go down.
A year later,
that is this morning,
I wanted to see what First
Federal Financial was doing.
Actually, it's still in
business;
everything is all right.
It has positive earnings but
the price was $70 in beginning
of 2007 and now it's down to
about $40 in 2008.
This is a testimony to
efficient markets.
The market was expecting the
price-earnings ratio--they gave
it a low P/E because they were
worried about--they had
information that there was
something going badly in this
company and indeed,
they were right.
It's not as bad as you might
have thought with the
Business Week story but
it is bad.
I guess the lesson--are you
following what I'm talking--what
happened was they did get into
trouble.
The low P/E was indeed a
forecaster of bad performance
later.
Now, I guess this isn't
exactly--efficient markets
wouldn't--in this case,
the people who sold First
Federal Financial short made a
lot of money when the price went
down so much.
That's not really consistent
with efficient markets because
it makes it sound like--as a
matter of fact,
I could have--Reading the
Business Week article at
the beginning of 2007,
I could have called my broker
and I could have told my broker,
short–please,
I want to short First Federal
Financial.
I could have done that and it
looks like I would have made a
lot of money by shorting it
because the price went down a
lot.
Efficient markets theory would
have to say that that was an
anomaly--that that was just good
luck.
Those people who shorted First
Federal Financial did make a lot
of money but,
hey, they were just lucky this
time.
In other words,
efficient markets theory would
say that the price was already
down as far as it
would--basically as far as it
would go in 2007 and that
earnings would fall and
dividends would fall later and
that would explain why the price
was low.
But, it wouldn't allow you to
predict the price.
This anomaly of--the fact that
it worked out so well is really
not--to short investors--is
really not testimony to
efficient markets.
Efficient markets--in some
sense I think I'm sympathetic to
efficient markets.
You have to be sympathetic to
some extent.
If I were trying--I actually
did not short First Federal
Financial when I read this last
year and it was because,
I guess, I had my doubt;
I had my feeling.
You read a Business Week
article and it's--everyone in
the world knows it now that a
lot people doubt First Federal
Financial.
If I come in late as a short
seller, am I going to do well?
I start to doubt it myself
because there are so many people
looking at it and so many people
who are more knowledgeable about
First Federal Financial than I
am;
so, maybe I won't try shorting
it.
That's what efficient markets
is all about.
The efficient markets theory
became very popular in finance
around 1970 and it became a
prominent theory in finance.
It has a particular incarnation
that I wanted to emphasize
called "random walk."
The random walk theory,
which follows loosely from this
formula, though I have to
qualify it--but let me talk
about random walk as a theory in
itself.
The random walk theory says
that under efficient markets,
stock prices and other
speculative asset prices are
random walks.
That term goes back to Karl
Pearson in an article in
Nature in 1905.
This idea is about a hundred
years old.
What Pearson wrote about
was–well,
the example he gave was a
drunk.
Imagine a person who is so
drunk that every step that
person takes is random and
independent of the preceding
step.
Suppose we--this is a 1905
story--suppose we had a lamppost
and we had a drunk standing at
the lamppost--I've drawn a
picture,
that's a lamp post and that's a
drunk.
This person is so intoxicated
that steps are completely random
and your objective is to predict
where will this person be in a
minute,
in ten minutes,
and twenty minutes.
Well, Pearson wrote about this
and said that the optimal
prediction is to assume that the
person in ten minutes--the best
forecast is the person will be
here.
In twenty minutes,
what's the best forecast?
The person will be here.
Of course, they probably won't
because they're randomly
staggering around but the point
is that if it's a true random
walk, there's no bias.
It's equally likely to go this
way or this way.
The most likely place for the
person is right where that
person is now.
So Pearson and other people
following him thought that
speculative prices are like
that.
That sounds like the markets
are crazy--they're drunk--but
they're not drunk.
It's because they respond only
to new information.
New information is,
by its essence,
unforecastable.
So, it has to look like the
market is driven by a drunk
when, in fact,
it's very precise and
responding optimally to new
information.
That's one of the paradoxes
that confuses people.
Statisticians developed the
theory of a random walk and let
me define that for you.
A random walk occurs when you
have a variable,
x, at time,
t, equal to x at
time (t –
1) + e_t where
e_t is
noise--unforecastable noise.
This is the random walk;
x would be here--how far
the person is from the lamppost.
Here's 0, let's say,
and x is the distance
from the lamppost.
At every time interval we have
x_t which is
how far the drunk has deviated
from the lamppost.
This is the random step;
this is where the drunk was
last period and this is where
the drunk is this period.
So that's a random walk.
In the heyday of efficient
markets theory,
people said that efficient
markets is working very well.
In other words,
the random walk hypothesis
describes stock prices very
well.
Let me go to my spreadsheet,
which I have up here,
and I'll put this spreadsheet
up on the web for you.
What I have here is
shown--there are two lines
shown, one is a blue line,
which is the--the blue line is
the actual Standard &
Poor's composite stock price
index going back to 1871.
This is a series that
I–well,
actually I got this series from
Standard &
Poor's and I emphasize it a lot
in my book.
It's a 130-year long stock
price series;
it's monthly for the United
States.
It's now called the S&P 500
because, starting in 1957,
Standard &
Poor's kind of reorganized the
index and they kept it at 500
stocks.
This is the second most famous
stock price index after the Dow
Jones Industrial Average.
I think it's better than the
Dow Jones Industrial Average
because the Dow has only 30
stocks and this has 500 and it's
representative of most of the
market.
That's history;
that blue line there is history.
What I did on Excel was I
generated a random walk,
because there's a random number
generator on Excel.
I used the random number
generator and plugged it into
this formula:
x_t =
x_t-1 +
e_t That pink
line is a true random walk.
It was generated by a random
number generator.
The point here is--don't they
look kind of similar?
When you look at--when people
look at stock prices they get
a--it's an illusion.
This is a psychological
illusion.
They get the sense that there
are bull markets when the market
is going up and there are bear
markets when the market is going
down.
There must be some force
pushing it up for a while.
You can see,
for example--I'm looking at the
blue line--there was a bull
market in the 1920s,
a famous bull market,
the Roaring 20s.
You would say,
that just can't be a random
walk;
it was just going up all the
time.
Then, this is the 1929 peak and
there's the crash from 1929 to
1932;
a big crash.
That can't be a random walk,
right?
That's what people think.
They have this intuitive idea.
But, if you look,
this random walk seems to do
the same thing.
The pink line has a--look
there's a nice bull market
there--there's another crash.
Look at this whole period here;
this was really strong and then
it leveled out.
We had bad--in fact,
they kind of look similar,
don't they?
This is pure chance because
that random walk that I
generated was pure random walk.
There's the bull--the actual
bull market of the 1950s and 60s
and my random walk comes out
pretty close to that.
The random walk theory says
that people are operating under
illusions;
that there really are no trends
or there's no way to predict the
market.
It is just completely
unforecastable.
Now incidentally,
a nice thing about Excel is I
can generate a new random walk
for you on the spot by pressing
F9--if you know that key on
Excel.
So, I will press F9 and history
is going to stay the same--the
blue line is going to stay the
same--but the pink line is going
to change.
I can generate whole
hundred-year history--pseudo
histories--with a press of a
button.
Let's see if this works,
we just got--what is that
saying?
I put an upward trend to the
random walk there because I
think there's an up trend to the
stock market.
It's a little different than
this, I just added a time trend;
otherwise, it's exactly the
random walk formula that I used.
Okay, that looks pretty much
like history too except we would
be in a bear market for quite a
while, right?
We have quite a bear market in
the pink line but I can correct
that by pressing F9 again.
This is bad luck,
the stock market crashed in
the--it went off the chart here;
that's bad luck but I can try
again.
Look at that one,
isn't that a beauty?
That almost--it really looks
like the market we've had.
So, I can just go--it's just
amazing how fast this thing
generates.
I should stop.
Tell me when one looks really
interesting.
That's an interesting one.
That's--if that was the history
that we randomly had,
Jeremy Siegel would write not
just Stocks for the Long
Run.
He would be jubilant if the
returns on stocks--he would say
for a hundred years--this is 130
years--for 130 years stocks have
wonderfully outperformed the
market--outperformed other
things.
That is looking pretty good,
isn't it?
Now, I just press the button
and get--I'm not getting many
bad ones.
That probably has an uptrend in
it.
They all look similar, right?
The other thing I wanted to
talk about was another thing
called an AR-1,
which is a different story.
The AR-1--this is the random
walk, here.
The other idea is that--let me
do it intuitively first.
I'm going to tie an elastic
cord around the ankle of the
drunk and tie it to the
lamppost.
You see my elastic cord?
It's very loose at the
beginning so the drunk can move
freely but if it starts to get
stretchy,
when the drunk makes it all the
way over here,
then its really hard for--it's
pulling the drunk back.
That means it biases the drunk
back towards the starting point.
That's called an AR-1 or a
first order auto-regressive
model.
That means that there's
something--the random walk has
no center;
it just has a starting point.
It doesn't tend to go back
anywhere, but here we have a
center.
What do I call that?
I'll call it--x-bar is
this point here,
not necessarily 0.
It says that
(x_t -
x-bar) = x-bar +
Ï
(x_t
_– 1 -
x-bar) +
e_t.
Ï  lies between
minus one and positive one;
usually it's positive.
You see that?
So Ï --the smaller
Ï  is,
the tighter the elastic cord
is.
It gets pulled back by 1-
Ï  of the way back to
the x-bar in every time
period.
But then there's new noise that
adds onto it.
If there were no new noise,
then the drunk would just be
gradually pulled back;
but there's new noise,
so the drunk is not so
predictable.
That's another model of the
stock market but it's not an
efficient markets model.
The random walk is the
efficient markets model that
says, you can't profit by
trading because you just cannot
predict the changing price.
But with the first order
auto-regressive,
you can predict the change of
price, at least a little bit.
Well when it's--what goes up
comes down.
If the drunk is over here,
it tends to get pulled back
here;
if the drunk is over here,
it tends to get pulled back up.
So, that's the random walk
model.
I programmed into this program
an AR-1.
I go down here and click on it.
That looks very different,
doesn't it?
Maybe I didn't get the
parameters exactly right,
but let me just hit F9;
I'll get it so it looks better.
Well, it looks a little
different;
you can see a difference in
this?
That's because I chose
Ï  = .95 for that
diagram so it's kind of getting
tugged back to the trend.
Sometimes it's hard to tell.
I thought--can you tell the
difference between a random walk
and an AR-1?
It seems to be coming back
faster, so that looks different.
Well, with Ï  = .95
I guess it does look noticeably
different because it's coming
back pretty fast.
I have 130 years of
observations and it's coming
back 5% of the way every year,
so in five years it's 25% of
the way back.
I've got the cord too tight so
it's not fooling you,
right?
You can see a difference
between this AR-1 and the true
stock market.
The stock--so this is revealing
some truth to the efficient
markets hypothesis.
What if I made Ï  =
.99?
Then I think--I should have
done that instead of .95;
then it gets harder for you to
see the difference.
If I make Ï  = 1 in
this--what happens if I plug
Ï  = 1 into this
expression?
It comes back to the random
walk because the x-bars
drop out--because you've got
1*x-bar and you've got
minus x-bar over here so
they drop out of the equation
and you come back up here.
A random walk is just an AR-1
with a coefficient--of
Ï of 1.
Now, the point is then that we
can easily see that the stock
market is not strongly
mean-reverting or
trend-reverting.
It's somewhat--it may be
somewhat trend-revering;
it's very hard to tell whether
its Ï  is 1 or .99.
So, that's the point of my
little analysis here,
of random walk versus AR-1.
Now, the homework--the problem
set that you will have next
time--now you still haven't
turned in your second problem
set,
but I want to work ahead now to
the third one.
What I want you to do is to try
forecasting the stock market.
So, let me show you what I did
here and I want you to do
something.
You could use this spreadsheet
but I'm also encouraging you to
find your own data.
Here's my spreadsheet,
which has stock prices back to
1871.
Can you see all this?
I have this on my website all
the time;
I've had it on my website how
long?
It must be twenty years.
I give it away because I'm the
person who updates S&P data
for 1871 to the present.
I now have a relationship with
S&P because they're
publishing our indices,
but they still don't provide
updates of this hundred
year-long series.
So, here it is all the way back
to 1871.
What do I have here?
I have in column one is the
Standard &
Poor composite stock price
index--today called the S&P
500.
This is the dividend on the
S&P 500.
They've been paying a dividend
consistently;
it has never missed a year.
Maybe some companies have
missed a year,
like Berkshire Hathaway or
Microsoft, but the whole
aggregate has never missed a
year.
This is the earnings report on
the company.
It's all per share so this is
per share earnings.
I have here the Consumer Price
Index in this column and then
I've got long-term interest
rates and I can convert it into
a real price by dividing by the
Consumer Price Index.
This is the change in the real
price.
I don't--it's between this year
and the next year.
What I wanted to do is--this is
your homework assignment and
maybe I'll come back to this or
maybe your T.A.'s will come back
to it as well.
I want you to try to forecast
the stock market.
What that means--remember what
you're trying to forecast.
You're trying to forecast
e;
you're not trying to forecast
x.
We already know x, it's
easy to forecast;
it's close to what it was last
period.
The hard thing is to predict
where the next change will be.
So, I had to generate a column
of data here,
which is the change in the
price.
You see, up here it says J10
minus J9 is the change in the
price;
that's what you want to try to
forecast.
I've created this column going
all the way back to 1871,
showing for each year how much
the S&P composite index,
in real terms,
changed.
I did it in logs.
I took the change in the logs
of real price.
That's essentially the
percentage change.
That is going to be hard to
forecast.
Obviously, it's going to be
hard to forecast because there's
some truth to the efficient
markets hypothesis.
If that were easy to forecast,
you could have been rich over
this period--somebody could have
been rich.
It can't be that easy.
Nonetheless,
the problem set for you is to
try to do that--to try to
forecast it.
What you have to do is go to
regression analysis.
You don't have to use Excel but
that's just what I'm suggesting
here because that's the easiest
thing.
To run a regression,
you go up to Tools and--let me
see--Data Analysis is down
here--and then you go to
Regression.
I guess I have to say "okay."
Then it asks you to fill in
your "x range" and your
"y range."
The x-variable is
the--remember the regression
model is--it's y = Î±
+Î²x + some error
term,
e or u--I'll call
it u so we don't get it mixed
up.
It's asking you to say where
your y-variable is and
I've got that that my y
variable is in column K,
because that's what I've
generated.
That's the change--where is K?
I've lost it;
it's not column K,
it's--I'm trying to find it
here--it's column I,
isn't it?
That's the change in price.
Then the x-variable--I
can pick some variable to
forecast.
What I did is I just took
column A, which is time--it's
just the year--and I ran the
regression since 1950 and I got
the results here.
I'm just going to show you the
results from what regression I
ran.
That's how Excel prints out
regression results.
The Î±, which is the
intercept, is shown here--so the
intercept was .05.
The Î²is the coefficient of
the variable is -2 times
10^(-5).
You can see now I've struck out;
it doesn't like time as a
forecaster--it's a very small
coefficient.
The t-statistic is a
measure of statistical
significance and the
t-statistic should
probably be over two for a
statistical significance.
I've got insignificant
t-statistics for both
Î± and for Î².
The R^(2) is a measure of what
fraction of the dependent
variable y's variance I
have predicted.
It comes out with a fraction of
.000147--this is a not a
success.
This is not a get rich quick
story because I'm explaining
1/10,000th of the variance of
the stock market;
so I struck out.
I wasn't really trying that
hard, I just regressed the
returns on time.
The problem set for you is to
think about seeing if you can
forecast the market.
You don't have to use my data
set, you can use others and you
can go online and find them.
For example,
finance.yahoo.com has a lot of
indices, but you can find them
on other sites.
If you find some other data,
you can try to see if you can
beat me.
I'm not setting up a very high
standard for success.
If it were this bad,
efficient markets--well,
this looks good for efficient
markets theory.
What I thought you might do for
the problem set is to try to
think creatively about how to
forecast the market.
Let me say this:
I'm not--I'm going to have to
continue with my doubts about
efficient markets in another
lecture,
but I think that the story has
a good element of truth to it.
It has to be hard to beat the
market but it's oversold as
well, especially in academic
circles--I think us professors,
who are poor are--it's kind of
a wishful thinking bias.
We're not making much money and
you can't anyway and so we kind
of tend to overstate efficient
markets hypothesis.
On the other hand,
relative to your expectations
as naïve young people,
it may be a good thing to do to
overstate efficient markets
hypothesis.
It seems to be a lifecycle
effect where young people think,
I can surely predict the market
and then they get beaten down.
Brad Barber and Terry O'Dean
were professors at UC--at
different campuses of
California--teamed up with some
economists from Taiwan and
looked at data of--they got
really good data from Taiwan
about day traders and their
actual returns.
Day traders are people who
trade everyday in the markets
and they found that there was a
really predictable pattern.
The young people--they start in
as a day trader and they quickly
lose everything;
they lose badly because they're
trading too much and they really
can't predict the market.
There's like 1% of them,
though, who seem like they can
actually beat the market.
This looks like really good for
efficient markets.
They found that there are some
Taiwanese people who know how to
beat the market--1% survives and
stays in.
Is that contrary to efficient
markets?
Well, it does seem contrary
because they found that a small
number of people did find some
forecasting rule and succeeded.
On the other hand,
none of the--hardly any of them
got really rich and so it's very
rare--Warren Buffett is an
extremely rare outcome.
So it's--I guess,
when I talk about efficient
markets I want to help prevent
you from suffering under any
delusions about your forecasting
ability.
I don't mean that Warren
Buffett can't do it or that you
can't do it if you develop
yourself into a Warren Buffett.
The next problem set,
number three,
asks you to think creatively
about how you would forecast the
market and to take a stab at it
by running a regression.
I expect you all to fail--or
almost all of you to fail.
Your grade will not depend on
your success in forecasting;
it may even depend inversely
because if you show a big
success in forecasting,
your teaching assistant will
look at it very carefully and
try to find some mistake you
made because,
if you do succeed,
it's probably a mistake.
On the other hand,
I don't want to tell you that
you can't because,
as I said--we're going to come
back to this--I have doubts
about efficient markets and I
think that you just might be
able to do it if you're smart
about it.